wir wissen dass das potenzielle
sogenannte amoktäter sich sehr für
andere amok-taten interessieren
und dann das oft als anlass nehmen dann
das umzusetzen was sie vielleicht
längere zeit schon selber geplant habe
[Musik]
frank urbaniok ist der einflussreichste
und wohl auch bekannteste
gerichtspsychiater der schweiz
wenn die medien fragen haben liefert er
antworten
wir sprechen mit ihm über die
eindrücklichsten fälle mit denen er als
gutachter zu tun hat am 27 september
2001 stürmte ein schwer bewaffneter mann
in das kantonsparlament den zug tötete
dort 14 anwesende und verletzte
zahlreiche zum teil schwer
er selber tötete sich noch am tatort
vorausgegangen war eine kneipen
auseinandersetzung drei jahre zuvor in
deren rahmen dieser täter ein busfahrer
mit einer schusswaffe bedrohte
das gab eine straff ermittlung und der
täter selber startete dann geradezu eine
kampagne gegen den busfahrer indem er
ihn beschuldigte wäre alkoholiker indem
er ihnen diffamierte und der versuchte
auf das strafverfahren mit ganz vielen
eingaben und beschwerden zu sabotieren
das führte dann unter anderem wieder zu
anzeigen seitens der zucker
verkehrsbetriebe auf die ihr dann wieder
mit neuen kampagnen und eingaben usw
reagierte und dieser ganze streit war
drei tage zuvor dann durchs obergericht
entschieden wurden worden in dem alle
seine vielfachen beschwerden abgewiesen
war friedrich leibacher gelangte
daraufhin mit mehreren waffen und einem
sprengsatz unbehelligt ins zuger
parlamentsgebäude
gekleidet in eine selbst gefertigte
polizeiuniform
also diejenigen die sagen da ist ein
braver bürger der einfach die kontrolle
verliert weil er durch behörden
schikaniert wird ist in dem fall
vollkommen absurd das ist eine person
die seit jugendjahren auffällig ist mit
gewalttaten mit eigentumsdelikten das
zieht sich wie ein roter faden durch die
ganze geschichte
es zieht sich auch durch diese
geschichte dass er ein großes geschick
hatte den spieß um zu kehren wenn er
angegriffen war wenn er beschuldigt war
dann reagierte er mit gegen
beschuldigungen mit kampagnen mit
eingaben er hat ja auch einige semester
jura studiert und hatte sich sozusagen
ein wissen angeeignet wie man dagegen
vorgehen kann und aber die wenn man die
lebensgeschichte sieht da findet man
sexualdelikt befindet gibt es drei
partnerschaften die er massiv schlägt
mit erheblicher gewalt tätigkeit es gibt
gewalt ein gewaltdelikt in zürich also
zieht sich kann man sagen eine vielzahl
von delikten auch schweren delikten
durch die ganze biografie und es völlig
absurd das bild zu transportieren ein
unbescholtener bürger wird durch den
staat schikaniert und verliert dann die
kontrolle
hier haben wir es zu tun mit einem hoch
manipulativen menschen mit krimineller
energie ein gewalttäter der in einer
bestimmten situation ganz kalkuliert ein
delikt begeht indem er subjektiv das
zurückzahlt ist allen den zeigt von
denen er glaubt dass er dort auf eine
rechnungen hat
es ist morgens um halb elf als laibacher
innert weniger minuten ein blutbad
anrichtet es ist der erste anschlag
dieser art in der schweiz
urbaniok wird beauftragt ein gutachten
über den toten täter zu verfassen
in dem fall lagen nach günstige
voraussetzungen vor weil der täter
selber unglaublich viel geschrieben hat
er hat so eine querulatorische seite
während der tagebuch geführt also es war
kein mangel an dokumenten das sind
tausende von seiten gewesen
es gab auch tagebuchaufzeichnungen und
das war schon eine sehr gute grundlage
die biografie zu rekonstruieren der
zweite punkt war es gab frühere
strafverfahren in denen schon viel
dokumentiert war die waren bis dato aber
nicht zusammengeführt das war eine
wichtige quelle und es gab personen die
den täter kannten aus der kindheit aus
der jugend zuletzt aus den
lebenssituationen und wenn man das alles
zusammen nahmen dann gab es in diesem
fall sogar eine überdurchschnittlich
gute informationsbasis laibacher machte
seine drohungen wahr
das heißt noch lange nicht dass alle die
drohen gefährlich sind die meisten
menschen bedrohen beginn keine taten
fast immer sind drohen harmlos fast
immer jetzt kommt das fast immer wenn
die drohung zusammentrifft mit einer
risiko persönlichkeit also mit einer
persönlichkeit in der es eigenschaften
gibt die die verstärkt zu gewalt
disponieren also wenn es die kombi gibt
drohung vielleicht konkrete drohung
zusammen mit einer risiko persönlichkeit
dann ist das die kritische mischung und
um das zu erkennen sind wir dann wieder
in den normalen gebiet der forensischen
risikokalkulation diese personen sich
anschauen schauen welche eigenschaften
hat sie uns sind die eigenschaften dabei
die ein besonderes risiko bedeuten nur
wenn die kombi vorliegt persönliche
risikofaktoren plus gefährliche drohung
ist es gefährlich das ist nur ein
kleiner anteil von drogen aber es ist
ein hoch relevanter auffällig ist der
zeitpunkt des amoklaufes kurz nach den
anschlägen auf die twin towers in new
york
ein detail in diesem fall ist auch dass
dieser täter vor dem fernseher saß und
mein eleven gesehen hat und völlig
fasziniert davon war
fand das positiv fand das toll ist
faszinierte ihn
und das ist aus meiner sicht auch kein
zufall dass er dann gut zwei wochen
später selber so ein delikt begeht weil
wir wissen dass das potenzielle
sogenannte amoktäter sich sehr für
andere amok-taten interessieren und dann
das oft als anlass nehmen dann das
umzusetzen was sie vielleicht längere
zeit schon selber geplant haben kurz
nach der tat interviewte das schweizer
fernsehen einen der den zuger behörden
ebenfalls bestens bekannt war
durch seine drogen vor laufender kamera
dachte er laut über einen amoklauf nach
wenn sie sich selber stelle ich hab das
verantwortungslos gefunden weil in so
einer zeit in so einer zugespitzten
situation man muss sich auch die
situation in zug noch mal vorstellen die
der ganze kanton war unter schock viele
personen kannten jemand zum teil aus der
familie waren menschen opfer geworden
und wir saßen da in einer task force
zusammen und hat einen fälle von denen
man annehmen musste könnten die
nachahmungstäter sein könnte die jetzt
auf den zug aufspringen
da gab es einige kündigten so etwas an
und in einer so aufgeheizten schwierigen
situation dann jemanden noch eine
plattform im fernsehen zu geben
da wird so ein fall und die publizität
auf eine schlechte art und weise
instrumentalisiert
das sf berichtet heute anders über
gewalttäter und die re gewalttaten
seines islamistische terroristen im
nahen osten
oder der rechtsradikal motivierte
massenmord im neuseeländischen
christchurch tritt 50 toten
[Musik]
oder der norweger anders breivik
also zum einen ist es ganz wichtig dass
man solche täter nicht noch ungewollt
idealisiert und das passiert schon
schnell durch die superlative in denen
man dann sagt der größte massenmörder
aller zeiten so etwas und dann
vielleicht noch in einer heroischen
geste zeigt wir haben es bei breivik
gesehen und man muss sich immer als
medien schaffen dann glaube ich muss man
sich immer vor allem eine frage stellen
wenn man berichtet über solche fälle die
eine frage ist die das was ich jetzt
produziere an aussagen oder bilder kann
das bei verwirrten geistern kultstatus
erlangen wir kennen die diskussion bei 3
weg das victory zeichen
das sollte man als gegenprobe sich immer
fragen können dadurch menschen die da
ein kult rausmachen nehmen die das
dankbar auf sind der idealisierung und
das zweite ganz wichtige was man sagen
muss man sollte sich in die opfer
hineinversetzen um sich wirklich
überlegen für die betroffenen für die
opfer vielleicht für die situation ist
ein bestimmter beitrag für die
retraumatisierung ist es für die
vielleicht sogar bedrohlich und wenn das
der fall ist dann sollte man die finger
davon lassen